first a word about the title here
cultural learnings of India for make
benefit glorious field of HCI now I gave
this seminar about five years ago or
something like that and there weren't
that many people that showed up and so i
was thinking what can i do to try to get
more people to come and I thought well
one thing might be that any
post-colonial theorists type person
can't possibly resist coming for a title
like this you know because of the notion
of just self-righteous flagellation of a
clueless industrial researcher in India
and so here it is but a little bit of a
bait and switch I'm not really going to
be doing much in the way of
post-colonial Theory work this is really
fundamentally in HCI talk and but for
those of you who remember this maybe I
don't know how many of you actually
recognize this title I think maybe a few
of you but I'm bet you're all really
really hoping that I've got a picture of
me and a mankini uh I don't but I do
have this really stupid inappropriate
picture of me showing really what
happens when you get sucked into a
wedding in India and they decide to wrap
your head up in a bright pink turban so
what did I'm what am i doing in India
about six years ago I decided to go to
India to try to understand how
technology could be used effectively in
as Michael said populations that are
traditionally not really included and a
lot of how we think about HD IO
technology there's a group there that's
called the technology for emerging
markets group and then I was invited to
come and hang out with them and it was
kind of a life-changing experience for
me and then the leader of that group
decided to leave and they were like you
you want to come do this it's like um ok
so I moved out there and so I've been
out there for six years so what i
thought i would do today is tell you a
little bit
about some of what I've experienced in
that time that may apply well to how we
understand HCI in design more generally
both in India and and everywhere else we
work and just some of some of the work
that we've done there that's shown but
first a little bit of background
Microsoft Research India this is where
we are and it's a fairly traditional
industrial research lab so we do
foundations machine learning kinds of
things systems and then there's this one
here which is the most important group
at MSR India and this is the one that
I've had the pleasure and honor to
manage for the last several years
basically the point of what we're about
is being able to first off understand
how people in these developing regions
and these developing economies are using
technology now how are they using it now
and how might they want to use the
technology then what we want to do is
take that understanding and apply it to
design use the design then to create
interesting prototypes innovations other
kinds of things and then test it find
out if it actually makes sense if it
works if it does work then the next step
is then to scale it and we do that
primarily with collaboration through a
variety of partners that includes
development organizations government
academics and then microsoft itself in
order to do this we really have a model
of an intensely multidisciplinary group
and it spans from people to technology
and then back to people again so it
includes an ethnographer linguists
people in design people in more
traditional HDI kind of interaction and
then really hardcore computer science
and engineering and the idea is by
bringing all these people together and
transcending these boundaries there are
a lot of times sort of thought about in
more siloed kind of experiences we're
able to do a lot more interesting work
alright so that's the that's the basic
background of what we're up to
in the group we have traditionally been
an ict4d now this is a some alphabet
soup it means information and
communication technologies for
development the idea is that it's really
focused on global development kinds of
questions but that's not all we do and
we're actually quite interested in sort
of expanding that mandate a bit into
looking at innovations that are sort of
unique for emerging economies in places
like India like Africa Southeast Asia
China somewhat we haven't really done a
lot of work in China most of the work
that we're doing right now and this just
has to do with who is in group is
focused on things like education
healthcare livelihoods and money the way
we think about money what is digital
money how do we think about also work
and the nature of work and then some
more traditional things in HCI in
emerging markets so ict4d is not really
necessarily HDI but it turns out that
HDI is really important for the way we
think about ict4d because it's really
about understanding how people are using
these technologies and so what we're
trying to do here is to think about this
combination of these things to create
HCI 4d and so that's really what i'm
going to talk about today all right
that's the setup alright so the first
thing I want to tell you about the first
project was something we did a couple of
years ago this was with a couple of
interns there's Nicole Adele Vidya have
I done up and running MIDI and then bill
tease in the lab and the the the
motivation for this work is that over
the years we had seen repeatedly that
when we started to try to explore our
technologies and understand how they
were being used by people that people
would tell us almost anything it was
very hard to get a straight answer from
people about what was really going on
and we decided to just like formalize
a little bit and see what happens now
essentially what happened was that bill
and Nikki had come up to me and they
said we're going to do this experiment
it's going to show how people will tell
you whatever they want to tell you and I
was like well we've done that forever
like people in psychology have known
about that since the 60s like this is a
really well known thing and Nikki was
like going I just have almost finished
my HCI curriculum and I have never ever
heard about this before and we said ha
there's actually an interesting
opportunity here to actually communicate
a bunch of this prior work in psychology
to the HCI audience and there may be
actually a need for this now
traditionally the idea is it's it's
something that's called demand
characteristics and demand
characteristics are the parts of an
experiment that communicate in some way
subtly indirectly some man some some
fashion what the experimenter is
expecting to hear now what that means is
that then the people can respond in
various ways and they might respond
positively might respond negatively but
the point is that you're not actually
getting an accurate representation of
what you think you're getting now
traditionally most of the time this has
been done just with psychology students
in the US and so we thought that there
actually might be something a little bit
special in the Indian context so we
decided to explore here so the
fundamental idea here is do you like my
thing okay and so the idea here is that
in HCI and is probably most of you guys
know and certainly in ICT 40 a lot of
what people do you just take it face
grant face value so they tell you
something and you say you like it or you
don't like it now increasingly the
people that we're studying are really
really different and there's really
dramatic different power characteristics
and relations associated with that so
for instance when this guy happens to be
talkin to a farmer in rural India
there's a really dramatic different
power differential there likewise
if I'm working with children in Silicon
Valley that's still a really different
kind of experience and the children are
going to tell me something probably
quite different than what an adult would
tell me so how do we understand this so
our basic objectives were first off to
just demonstrate this known thing about
response bias due to due to demand
characteristics and then we wanted to
communicate this to HCI researchers
generally so that's that was the point
of the experiment so what we do alright
essentially what we did was we took two
smartphones and we had a 20 second clip
of a little video and there are
identical smartphones and we played them
for people and we asked them which one
they preferred one of the smartphones
was associated with an experimenter and
a certain way i'll show you in a moment
how it is and then we just asked people
do like this one do you like this one
are they both the same now remember
there are identical videos on identical
smartphones so this was a basic script I
mean the important point here is the
yellow bits are the pieces that changed
when we were trying to push the the
association okay so essentially what we
said is hi this is my one look at them
both and tell me which one you like
alright so the participants it's a
little more complex than just this so
let me explain who the interviewers were
one of the things that we were
interested in was looking at this notion
of something called social distance and
the way we were thinking about this was
let's look at people who are local and
people who are really really different
from the people that working with so
Vidya was actually hyperlocal she was
from the area in which we were actually
studying these people she had grown up
there all her life she spoke to local
language which was canada and had been
living there in malaysia shoreham
forever and so she was one of our
experimenters then you've got Nikki
Nikki was from Zimbabwe blonde the both
female because we wanted to keep that at
least static
in both cases but they're really very
very different at least on the surface
and of course she only speaks English
the participants all right so what we
did was we had 450 participants they
were from two groups of people so the
first was from the indian institute of
science the indian institute of science
is one of the elite institutions in
India it's in bangalore and it's
basically a graduate kind of a program i
think they may have some undergrads now
there but it's one of the very elite
kinds of places and it's very close to
where our lab was located we also just
got a bunch of auto Wallace so oughta
wallahs are the people who drive around
in auto rickshaws so you may have heard
of them as tuk tuks in some parts of the
world and so these were two populations
of people the first experiment was we
wanted to say these are the folks that
are closest to us right so these are the
people that are most similar to both of
our two people there so we got 50
students interacted with Vidya and fifty
students interacted with Nicky we had a
standard script and then we randomize
the order in which we presented the two
things so that at least there wouldn't
be an order effect their associated with
them alright so what do we get well on
the whole we get a really strong
response bias okay so this is averaged
across both Nicki and Vidya so you can
see about there's a two-to-one
preference for my player even though
they're identical okay but just by
saying this is mine and giving people
that sense it's about two to one but
then when we split it up into both Nicki
and Vidya it's also just about exactly
the same and so essentially the notion
here is that these students didn't
really make that much distinction
between Vidya and Nicki they're fairly
sophisticated students and so that was
fine experiment two we go to auto
rickshaw drivers and in this case we
have 50 drivers interacting first off
with the foreign interviewers but Vidya
is there with her because we need a
translator okay so we have the white
woman with a
local translator talking to the auto
drivers and then we also have Vidya just
talking to the auto drivers by yourself
again standard script counterbalanced we
get a really dramatic difference here
and notice for the foreign it's a five
to one advantage over just the local so
this is about the same kind of pattern
that we saw in is see where it was a
local familiar person but when we have
the foreigner with a very large
difference in sort of social distinction
we get this really dramatic difference
here okay this is pretty yes the first
experiment was it was it in local
language or all enabled sure there's all
English mm-hmm whereas here was I guess
technically all local but there's all
Canada here so it's all local language
here but we're translated yeah all right
now it's possible that yes so what's the
hypothesis why why is there such big
difference the general sense the
hypothesis here is that as we increase
the social distance of the interviewer
in the people there's going to be more
pressure to have some response bias
associated with it now it might be both
positive or it might be negative there's
some places we've seen in ittt work but
basically the people just want to screw
with you and the more different you are
then the more likely they are to want to
sabotage your work in this case one of
the things we had seen repeatedly in
India is that the more difference there
was in social relationship between the
people the more likely they were just
going to defer to you but
keeping cozy so both of our interviewers
are female all of the interviewees are
male probably i've started seen it suck
but we were trying to keep this fairly
controlled yes is that in one condition
though there is an observer and so I
guess another possible hypothesis II
thought they may not want to embarrass
somebody in front of somebody else
that's possible they're actually hold on
to that per minute let's let's let's
move along a little bit so now we were
like well okay this is I believe the
results here but they really are
identical players and so it's easy you
can imagine that they're just sort of
giving you the benefit of doubt so we
decided in this case to take one of the
players and dramatically screw it up so
we reduce the resolution in half and we
cut the frame rate in half as well
actually the the resolution is less is
more than hat okay so dramatically
reduce a resolution reduce a frame rate
make it look really crappy okay now and
the idea is that the interviewer is only
ever associated with a crappy clip okay
so we never really switch that around so
let's see what happens so we had an ISC
students so these are the folks that we
think are closest to toe the social
standard in fact what we see is that
when we do no association first up we do
the control to just make sure people can
tell the difference right because you
want to make sure that in fact you're
trying to make a really crappy version
they can tell and they clearly can tell
because they prefer the high quality
version when there's no association when
there is an association V is a slight
bump here but it's not too bad yeah
agency Jerusha Byzantine both Jesus
there are college dropouts all right so
yeah yeah this is there water of you sir
all right so so in general it seems as
though the ISC students are pretty you
know they're telling it like it tell it
like it is what happens we go to the
rickshaw drivers so in this case we have
50 rickshaw drivers we have we have them
with the translator so it's the
foreigner with the translator but no
associations we just want to make sure
they can tell the difference okay and
then we also then have it with a foreign
interviewer Associated low quality video
and then just the local associate of low
quality video makes sense okay so first
no association clearly the auto drivers
can tell a difference they prefer the
high quality one when vidya the local is
looking at it they still prefer the high
quality one the reference player my
player is still bumped up so there you
get a pretty good jump there so we're
already seeing that this effect and when
it's Nikki you get a complete reversal
now so you've got a majority of people
in this case actually saying I prefer an
objectively really crappy experience
just because you had this foreigner
asking you about it so this is pretty
interesting and then the idea here that
we really suggesting is that a big
social difference can dramatically in
fact in fact it can cause someone to
prefer an obviously inferior experience
now this is kind of a big deal with your
designer doing user studies right now
the notion here is that if you don't do
anything else you're potentially stuck
with a real problematic situation now we
were curious how they actually even
explain this to us so we asked them like
well what's different about these things
tell me something about it and so in the
iasc they clearly were making up narrow
about why the one associated with the
experimenter was so much better so there
are things like oh your framerate is
better and it's reducing the blur a
little bit and I think if you do just a
little more work on this it's going to
be great and you know go get them tiger
um you know all the way down to things
like well I don't know why it just it's
just better okay but the autorickshaw
drivers as well you know they were
saying things like um the quality of the
background is better and and the color
is better in yours and is it going to be
available by this thing that's great you
know I really like this quote where they
say I prefer this one because the other
one wasn't clear at all this one was
fully cleared and I definitely show you
the difference if we watch them together
now I've given you my honest opinion so
don't be cross with me you know if this
isn't right and so you can get a sense
that they're actually sort of like in
their head making up a justification for
why they're preferring the one to the
other it's okay simply put how do we
think about recommend recommendations
associated with now one of the things
that's really simple it's something that
we do in almost all of our work now is
to the degree possible we really try to
dissociate ourselves from any particular
design and that's not always possible
because often if you're doing a new
design it's clearly something new and
especially if you're doing it to
something some reference but the other
thing you can do is try to minimize the
social difference between the
investigators get locals get somebody
that you know is there to actually help
you out and working with these things
but I think probably the biggest
important thing to do here is using
triangulation and that's using other
mechanisms you know things like these
kinds of user studies are really
important they tell you a lot of
information you get a lot of good detail
from them but if that's all you use
you're at risk for really getting bad
information about it and so you really
need to use other kinds of methodologies
to yes I'm curious like the implication
of this for you know a big company like
Microsoft that's and what
companies like Google they either will
send people from their main much of
who's gonna have a lot of them people at
Google is from maybe a little more of a
lot here and they'll send usability
researchers off to these places where
they don't have the cultural context
that's one way or another to hire
offender but then when they do that
there's kind of a disconnect between
them understanding what you're doing so
I'm kind of curious ask that how do you
think the right way for a company that
maybe we have an unlimited budget kind
of yeah yeah that I mean I've watched
this exactly what you're describing
cause a lot of problems a lot of bad
information get back to the mothership
because either the people that are there
a parachuting in and they're just
staying at five star hotels and blah
blah blah and they really don't have any
real good sense of what the hell's going
on or the vendors themselves are telling
what they believe the people want them
to know and so one of the things that we
we do think is important is having
people with at least some kind of
cultural context on the ground there now
that's not cheap and it's hard to do
that across everything you know I nithya
probably experiences this all the time
because she's a google and she is going
all over the world and you can't have
these people everywhere so I don't have
a good answer for you but I think it's
as much as anything be sensitive of the
fact that this is going on and to
probably be a little bit suspicious of
the results you get back and aware that
that it's happening in fact that's
actually what the next thing I'm going
to tell you about a little bit is an way
in which this worked out so you know
here's basically this the main findings
and I won't go over this but yes is
there would you expect the difference
between your control condition which was
essentially the absence of any
association of the experiments are with
with either and the flipping that and
associating with both the reason I
is that we often teach our students here
to say well we I've created two
different prototypes and I'm trying to
figure out which one I should be
pursuing this is sort of like also sort
to keep it all kind of thing I'm
wondering is that would that be the same
or different than just saying like no
I'm I'm testing the sunny have some
other people or something it is
different but the thing to be very aware
of is and this is where are the warm
work in becomes important is being super
careful not to communicate the fact that
you still have some a field affiliation
you can tell people these are both mine
I'm trying to figure out which one's
better almost everybody has a favorite
you have something that you're basically
trying to really push on and and the
real key is to try to figure out how you
can dissociate from that and but
potatoes your question it's certainly
better than this I mean this is an
example of taking a hammer and just
bashing it pretty hard and so certainly
the your your discussion is a better way
of doing it and its design thinkers or
like I do in particular seem to have
really dialed it in how to get like
really valid user feedback what's your
take on like this other well basically
there they triangulate the hell out of
it they use a lot of different
methodologies and they use some a lot of
dense ethnomethodology zaz well like
watching people in context using things
and how they're using it it actually the
next topic i'm going to talk about shows
how that actually plays out in another
project it's one more yes so you
measured a preference kind of binary
preference you like this and more
there's one more I would be curious to
see a kind of the degree of criticism
they were willing to or willingness to
give criticism umm annar thought that
was somehow
anything I can imagine like if they were
not willing to give criticism at all
they were probably more willing to just
go with whatever so the the ISC students
that the students were willing to give
criticism in general like you notice the
net 1feedback there they're talking
about like frame rate and color and
stuff like that and and in the butt auto
rickshaw drivers absolutely not it's I
mean they're bewildered like why is this
random lady stopping on the side of the
road and like doing this this thing but
they're happy to go along and they'll
answer us but but they're certainly not
going to criticize in that case a higher
resolution actually didn't they're
really really I think they were afraid
of like pissing us off yeah that's
really a diesel yeah alright let's move
along all right this next study is now
pulling into a I ctd space okay
now this is one of the things we're
doing is we were trying to explore a way
in which some technologies might be used
in some monitoring of child malnutrition
okay so they're two papers associated
with us and I'll explain why and in just
a few minutes so we now are in the conv
district of madhya pradesh so this is in
really kind of the hinterlands of india
it's very remote very poor
infrastructure in this place and there's
a lot of bowel nutrition part of my
throat i'm in at a conference all week
it's basically completely toasted now so
our partner in this case is rnf this is
the real medicine foundation these guys
go in two villages and various places
and they sort of try to combat childhood
malnutrition by sort of measuring where
it's happening and if you have an
outbreak or whatever then they go in and
they like move high-calorie stuff to
make sure the kids are
are taken care of now in general they're
these things called Sienese these are
community nutrition educators and what
they do is they go from village to
village and they measure the mid upper
arm circumference so they're these
little tapes and they look at the upper
arm of children you can see that's what
she's doing here and this turns out to
be a really good very low-cost metric
for measuring mid to severe malnutrition
now what happens is that the the
malnutrition malnourished children if
they find them are referred to what are
called augen body workers now the onion
body workers then are the ones who
actually take care of the children once
they determine it there's a problem so
it was a completely paper-based system
the way they were working and
essentially what happens is that the CNE
has a daily visit form and they have
another form which is a new Act register
this is the circumference register and
then they have a weekly report now the
daily visit and the weekly reports are
all sent up to the central office okay
the daily new Act register basically
just stays with the worker so the
central the main people that are paying
attention all diz and have to manage the
deployment of resources etc are only
really ever seeing the daily visit stuff
and a weekly reports now the problem is
that these things can take a long time
to get to the office and as you see here
these are basically monthly reports so
you can imagine if you identify a
severely malnourished child and then
basically summarized a month later
before the central office knows about
this there's not really serious lag here
it's a potential for a lot of very sick
or dead children so yeah so it's about
six six weeks between when they record
the information to what it actually gets
to the to the top office so we thought
there must be a good way to sort of
right there's a lot of problems with the
paper system there's really low
granularity people write really crappy
the big temporal lag is there it's one
way so they send the stuff up to the
Home Office but they never hear back so
there's no sense of like what's really
happened in that in that process and
then it often can take a really long
time to transcribe it because they get
all these forms and they've got to
transcribe all the stuff into the books
and then the books have to then be sent
off to the office in the office then
transcribed into Excel because there's
many many step system so some of the
design constraints we have to worry
about first off unsupervised Jewish the
Sienese have very little technical
experience so we need to make sure that
it's quite easy to use they don't have a
lot of experience working with phones or
other kinds of devices we've got very
bad electrical infrastructure so it's
maybe six hours a day of power and its
really really dirty power as well so you
get lots and lots of voltage spikes and
stuff like that the connectivity
infrastructure is very poor to very
frequently if you if it's there at all
it's not necessarily there throughout
the day and finally these are really
harsh environments so the robustness of
the device turns out to be really
important as well all right enter the
pen and paper digital slate now this was
a system that we had been working on for
several years with a different kind of
domain this was in we were working in
microfinance with this thing and it was
really successful it was working really
really well in fairly remote areas in
micro fine and so these are groups of
women who do group lending and they
needed to be able to take care and
measure like all of their financial
information so we had had this great
experience with this thing and we said I
wonder if this would work for this the
Sienese in the mounted trisha work
so how does it work essentially what
happens is that it's got a pen which has
its normal pen and paper but the slate
itself has an inductive recorder on it
so as you're writing we get real-time
data entry into this little guy it's a
very low cost little computational a bit
of information so because of that we're
able to because we know what the spacing
is on this thing we can get very good
regular knowing of this box equals this
kind of entry this box equals this kind
of entry and do the right thing with it
so we can process the entries against a
database we can output audio which in
some cases is actually a really big deal
because we have lots of non literate
populations as well and we thought this
would actually be just a really good
kind of technique now about the time we
started to pitch this to RMF the real
medicine foundation they were also
talking with de magie dhemaji is a
really interesting company they're in
there are social enterprise in boston
that build a lot of tools for healthcare
monitoring and people in the developing
area okay and so they were also going to
try out a little their own system at
about the same time we were going to try
out ours so this was a great experience
for us we were like perfect we'll do a
dual deployment will have half of the
people doing the tablet have the people
doing the phones why is the tablet cool
well first off it's really natural and
the experience it's basically exactly
what they've been doing all this time
which is just writing in their books so
that's really quite nice and it's very
easy especially in Hindi to do the kind
of data entry one thing that's a problem
with it is it's a very special purpose
device so it only does this now that's
both good and bad depending on how you
look at it the phone is a very common
device and they're everywhere it's
basically a low-end phone nokia but it's
a very complex interaction
and if you've ever tried to enter hindi
on nokia phone it's a really colossal
pain it's like many many taps in order
to do it it's not obvious how it works
it's actually quite hard to do so we
were fairly dubious if this was going to
work very well so the deployment is a
three-month study we had 20 of the
seeonee so we had 10 and 10 that were
given these devices now we had some of
these had mobile I think all of them had
a mobile at home but typically it was
their husbands and so the women were not
actually allowed to keep them very often
but we had one day training session with
first off one day it was full of
training for just a 10 with the phone
and then the other one was a training
session for the the tablet and then we
had you know just a lot of face-to-face
interviews the analysis of what the
artifacts were going to be what they'd
done with their phones etc that's the
the analysis part alright findings well
let's start with the phone what happened
with the phone first off it just worked
so the time for data collection dropped
from 45 days to 8 hours for all the data
including the individual paper data I'm
an individual patient data so this was a
dramatic improvement and pretty much the
real medicine foundation was blown away
by this because they were getting
everything they needed within a day the
completeness of the data went up by
almost twenty percent and this included
a bunch of information around counseling
the quality of the data improved
dramatically as well so we went from a
ten percent error rate on these things
down to zero and we could do that
because we can do a bunch of correction
like detection of problems so that's
really cool ok what about the digital
slate we got no data at all it
completely crashed and burned and so we
were like what is going on here
when we deployed this originally and
during the training it was the clear
favorite every trainer loved it all of
the women loved it it was the V bee's
knees for devices and they were really
into it they were really optimistic
about it and yet when we came back after
several months it was just it was a
disaster so what was going on here well
first off we buzz saw it into the
infrastructure issues so we had lots of
these power outages that I was talking
about now the problem with the slate is
that it would take up to six hours to
fully charge but so frequently what
would happen is that they wouldn't have
that long they would try to charge the
thing up the power outages would happen
so they would come away with a van only
partially powered device then the thing
would fail in the field and it would
embarrass the CNAs and so they were
really mortified that their device
they've been carrying around doesn't
even work now in contrast the phones
would charge like in an hour and a half
because they're really optimized for
this and they're great the comcast has a
particular connectivity thing which also
turned out to be really important
essentially it's really smart in that it
just detects when there might be some
signal and then it pushes a bunch of
data up when it's there and otherwise it
just caches everything in contrast for
us what we had to do was it was just a
side sharing so it's just a micro SD
chip you had to move around okay that's
one that's infrastructure another issue
which we completely didn't expect was
around social status and in respect
having that phone turned out to be a big
deal because it was kind of a social
symbol that I've been invested with this
bit of technology the other thing that
actually turned out to be quite
interesting was the camera on the phone
was used in this other way of
essentially convincing the augen body
workers to actually do their jobs so
some what would happen sometimes is that
they would come the Sienese or go to the
organ body workers say I've got this
child that has this problem the
eigenvalues work that's not my problem I
can't be bothered with that
and and the CNE is like but it's your
job and she's like yeah what are you
gonna do about it and they would take a
picture of the algan bodyworker and then
send it in to their boss and it sort of
worked as this little bit of proof of a
problem here another thing that actually
turned out to be a big deal was the
local support now there were there a
bunch of issues here first off the
slights kind of a funny shape and so it
made it really kind of challenging for
them to carry around a lot of the women
go around on the backs of their husbands
bicycles and they would crash often and
you're really worried about breaking
these devices because they can't keep
them in their in their bags from their
pockets it was also monsoon and so it's
raining all the time and they were they
would wrap these things up and lots and
lots of rolls of plastic but still water
would get in do these things they really
made them concerned the phones were a
tiny small and I could easily squirrel
it away and they're quite robust the
other thing is that these nokia phones
there's a repair ecology for these
everywhere and so if they break you can
just go to the local mobile shop and the
guy knows how to fix it and you can like
take it apart and start like working in
it there were several cases where they
took the slate to them to the mobile guy
and mobile guys like i don't know what
that is i can't do anything with that
and then it just stayed there until we
could get somebody else to come in and
sort of deal with it so that's really
sort of like the main thing that we saw
about why the slate crashed and burned
but there was another question that was
really curious to us which is why was
the phone so much more successful when
it was such a pain in the butt to use
and what we saw was that there's a whole
series of these cases this is a case of
a big poster board that one of the
Sienese had used and was having her kids
quiz her on how to do text entry
appropriately so every evening she would
go home and the kids would quiz her on
how to do effective
injury and Hendrick indie this is
another case of this so they've done the
same thing so they just made these up on
sort of how to do this effectively more
like you guys are doing an enormous
amount of work to figure out how to use
this thing which just seemed to us to be
crazy because it was so hard to use in
the first place and why would they do
that well it turns out that the reason
they're doing this is because it's a
phone so like the quotes here comcare
system is very nice we get better video
phones for our work my husband's phones
black and white it's a basic hansen and
you can't watch video films this has
nothing to do with their work it's
basically just a good phone and likewise
my husband's phone never used to have
enough balance so this is the talk time
for me to even give a missed call to my
sister and now I use this phone and my
sisters rich so I can give her a miss
call and she'll call me back I can talk
so what we see here is that what they
really cared about was the phone and the
phone was used really effectively for
work but they really wanted was the
phone itself as a phone and that's
particularly interesting here because
when we talk to them about the data
entry they're like well if we don't
learn how to use this effectively for
our work they're going to take these
phones away so we need to make damn sure
that we're actually using the phone
effectively so that we get to keep it
yeah this ends up being a negative
because like like say what the husband
realizes this that might just take the
phone and then you end up with no way in
our case this was not going to be the
case because they're getting paid to use
this phone so it's actually part of
their job so the husband might do that
if it were not part of their job but
because this is actually the government
has given this phone to the women and
said as part of your job and they're
getting paid for it they typically left
them alone I agree with you and we've
certainly seen that in the case
especially with kids we're like you know
the older brother will take away the
phone from younger sister and things
like that that certainly does happen
question how much it so there's glue
infrastructure and device differences
and wondering how much of it you can a
tribute to fact that you pit something
that was effectively a research
prototype
again it's something that was like a
product of engineered product that you
know was battle-hardened like this for
longitudinal deployments I agree this is
this is a very difficult thing not just
an ICT for DD like you know any HCI
research business issue was wondering
use your sense that if this kid you know
if the phone were terrible phone to like
would you have seen a different outcome
and we certainly worried about that it
is the case that by the time we got the
tablet to this point it had been used in
this other project quite a lot so we had
a lot of confidence in its effectiveness
and its stability but it was actually in
a somewhat supervised usage situation
there like when they had problems they
could go to somebody I figure out and
fix it here it's completely unsupervised
and so any problems that cropped up just
like turned up to nuke the whole thing
James really kind of weak in some ways
just not because of that idea that Cisco
it's not a commercial product that's
been engineered hard have infrastructure
to keep it supported and so I'm curious
this quote here you know whether this is
representative for example what if you
had given the person the tablet and the
phone and the phone was purely for like
sinking the data back through the
network but that app was an honor at all
she'd get all these other benefits of
the phone you know what dude will use it
for other things and then really get a
better understanding of whether I think
you would the one thing that doesn't
help is that then cost goes up
dramatically like part of one of the
things we're balancing here is cost the
the phone and a tablet where the tablet
is a little more money than the phone
but if you're having to do both then now
you just double the cost of the
deployment
again the tablet is in necessary what it
would cost if it was creeks and success
in a long run and so it's more how to
experimentally remove these commercial
scale factors that really you don't want
to be the reason for the result you
actually live and I I don't have a good
answer for you yeah yes question did you
guys learn anything from the study about
how to find these insights sooner like
without having to make the whole thing
like the size of it for example you
could have just had a prototype that
doesn't work at all and say carry around
with you and then you would have learned
it's too big or something well actually
no because that we didn't really see
this for like a couple of weeks in
because there was a big glow at the
beginning of everybody reeling really
into it and it just turns out that over
time it's like this is a pain like this
is not really dealing with what we
wanted to do the other problem is it is
a very remote site so we weren't on the
ground with them and it was actually
very hard for us to like we weren't
going to move to town blog district for
three months there's no way we're going
to do that and so that meant that any
time we were interacting with them it
was we would go there for like a few
days come back go there for a few days
come back then we had the phone but it
was actually the phone was we were
talking to them it was never to the
actual cnas the Sienese would kind of go
out and we would only hear about things
after they came back in and we're
interacting with their supervisors so
there might have been a way to do that
but I'm not sure exactly how it would be
it actually that's that it's in this
case I think we pretty it certainly
didn't need to be three months the
reason we let it go on for three months
is because the phone room was working so
we're like well let's study the phone
and in fact that's what the those two
papers one of those papers is basically
just about the phone and the other one
is about why the tablet crashed and
burned so it really wasn't a comparison
paper there
so again the differences between these
two things the tablet was incredibly
popular training and we just believe
that this was going to be what was going
to really work but again it wasn't used
unsupervised and the infrastructure
robustness issues all these kinds of
things the phone just worked and we got
all kinds of things happening there were
some things that happened that were not
expected the peel of its phone for
itself and its multi-use things was
actually turned out to be one of the
main things that really motivated use in
this which was surprising to us and
interesting and in fact this is
something that we've continued to talk
with dhemaji about as an intrinsic way
of maybe motivating workers and health
workers to buy their own devices because
this is a major cost for big NGOs is
buying all the devices and deploying
them and one of the ideas we had was
well you know if they're willing to go
halfsies on a phone with the NGO then
maybe and we let them use it for other
kinds of things as opposed to locking it
down then there's actually a potential
here for cost savings and for subsidies
on this stuff so I think we don't have a
lot of time left so I had another study
that was going to talk about that I'm
not going to do that and I think we'll
just stop and maybe chat a little bit
unless unless you just want to need to
jam through another study any questions
thoughts observations yes I guess this
wasn't a smartphone right did you
consider whether like switching to a
lower one of the lower cost smartphones
or something like would make a big
difference as opposed to using one of
these phones which don't have like I
mean this you're talking about typing in
particular i can imagine even a cheaper
smartphone would make it even
here for them like thank you there's
actually a lot of work right now the
interesting thing is that what's
happening we've just done a study on
this that's basically looking at a bunch
of NGOs and they're deploying some of
them are deploying some of these nokia
devices some of them are playing android
devices and it turns out that the
problem is that with android devices
it's really easy to lock them down and
so all of the NGOs are completely
locking them down and not allowing the
workers to use them for anything that
work whereas these nokia devices you
can't really do that and so they can use
them for these other things so there's
this funny thing that happens is with
with the additional power of the Android
devices and within much more utility it
also turns out to be way easier to keep
people from using it for the things you
didn't want them to use it for and and
so there's this really interesting
tension it's happening there and we're
not really sure how it's going to play
out but I think it's a net negative
because I actually think that there's
actually an opportunity for other kinds
of developmental improvements associated
with internet access with other kinds of
things like that that when they don't
have that when they're basically saying
you only get to use this device for this
thing now from that to be clear
organizations have a good reason for
wanting to lock these things down you
know these things get completely full of
porn they get full of photos they wind
up erasing all the data that they needed
it before they get viruses I mean
there's all kinds of things that happen
that really interfere with a basic
function that the NGO needs whatever
they just let them use it for whatever
and so they're really concerned about
that for good reason but I feel like
that there's a balance there that they
tend to just sort of like go completely
other side which I which i think is
problematic yes was mainly like a lot
about like your process that you learn
like so just a flaw in our methodology
like we need to make sure we do this
like what did you learn from this study
about your overall design process and
what would if you had to test another
device in the future would you follow
the same strategy
um it's a good question I think the main
thing that we really learned from this
was the importance of I don't think we
would have assumed that a three month
deployment was the right length of time
we probably would have shrunk down quite
a bit and then tried to do a much more
constrained short term kind of thing see
how it worked and maybe would we would
have seen some of these things early
enough on to either pull the plug on the
one or corrected and and try something
else and iterate but I mean part of this
is just the challenges of working in
these conditions it's it's just kind of
tough any other questions thoughts
observation Jess you talked about kind
of this alone we made the study with the
slate and the fun and those trees either
in this district or you've done your
search elsewhere um how problem is kind
of a mistrust of technology is that
something that you guys to do it at all
it is very little people love technology
I I have not seen it much myself they
may not know how to use at all but I see
very little distrust there's there's
used to be it's not so true anymore
there used to be a little bit of concern
about breaking it like especially if
you're trying it out with them they're
like you know this thing is worth more
than my entire monthly salary I'm kind
of nervous about that but but that even
now is less and less true and especially
with touch devices so direct inner
direct interaction of touch phones or
tablets etc just invites you to play
with it in a way that older kinds of
phones you don't do and like we saw
cases where people were really they were
reluctant they didn't really understand
this notion of soft buttons and things
like that they would like your buttons
that were associated with things in the
screen etc but with a direct interface
people just get it
and they go and it just sort of invites
them to touch and play interacting just
does what they think it's going to do
and it's so I'm very little okay so a
lot of the work that you've talked about
probably true for ICD would be in
general is that there is the artifact
and expat already and it's bad ready for
a certain setting which is wherever it's
been designed and that might be in the
Western world what have you and then you
use that argument in a new setting and
then it's not that bad really more right
so then a lot of your work seems to be
about that fourth moment where you have
this device seems to be fine and then
you have this new setting and this
device is no longer fine the other thing
of a new way of rethinking that device
but can i push you to think of looking
at it from another direction is that is
there something that HC I could be as a
team has offered back to HCI in terms of
newly thinking about design all together
so the way that Gary Mars Jen used to
talk about this and is this notion that
HDI 4d is just HCI it's it's not
different it's just extreme HD I it's
basically put in sort of extreme
environments and with extreme
constraints so you have to push a little
harder in in various ways but that it's
not really any different so I don't
think that there's fundamental new
insights that we learn from HCI 4d that
we don't learn from HCI more generally
it may be that it's quicker or that we
see it in maybe a new perspective I
think part of it and this is true for
design in general I mean if you think
about what is designed designed as
you've got a set of constraints and
you're trying to achieve some goal
within those constraints now with in HCI
4dr I ctd those constraints just happen
to be really pretty charmed and kind of
hard and so you'll get and you get a lot
more of them so you have things like
financial constraints you've got
infrastructure constraints you've got
literacy constraints you've got cold
constraints with gender and stuff like
that you've got constraints having to do
with total education I mean and just
data data data data and I think that one
of the things that I ctd or HCI 4d does
well for HCI is illustrating ways in
which you can manage around these very
large constraints and learn a lot
without necessarily resorting to
bleeding-edge technology as in a
conversation at lunch about this this is
one thing that's often a problem for
computer science students when they
think about ICT d is they're like well I
can't do any real research because none
of that stuff works and these in these
environments and it's like well the
research is just different and and I
think that's true for here as well but
we don't look at that because we're
we're really a lot more engaged in the
shiny new object of really the bleeding
edge of technology so I don't know if
that answers your question but that's my
rant thing else all right thank you so
much
you